[Music]
it might have been john doerr kleiner
perkins said if one time he said if
you're trying to figure out
if you're an entrepreneur you're not
which i always thought was kind of
interesting
if you need structure
there's nothing wrong with that big
companies need a lot of people
they're good places to work
and if if that's you
that's fine go big
lots of big companies recruiting here
lots of big companies are great places
to to work for entire careers career
transitions that i've watched are
historically quite easy from large
companies to small ones and quite hard
from small ones to large ones
and so
if you are going to go from a big
company background into the
entrepreneurial world
think long and hard about that because
it won't be that easy to go back where
you came from
um i mean maybe if it's a year or two
and you duck back quick or you go back
to the company you work for you might be
able to do it
but then i would almost say you weren't
really all that committed to going into
the startup world in the first place if
you were looking for an opportunity to
go back like i said if it scares you go
big
um
the
the the failures
particularly in the entrepreneurial
community here
are are really almost no big deal
but
they tend to be perceived as a much
bigger deal by the bigger companies the
bigger more mature companies and it's
just a fact of life i think you probably
many of you have probably
experienced that
so
i think the likelihood is if you are
committing to an entrepreneurial career
path
that's the commitment you need to make
and you need to probably
believe
that it's a career-long commitment that
that's where you're going to spend the
rest of your career can you handle the
risk
what will you do if it fails
some cultures
some geographies
failure's really hard
it's really hard to explain or somebody
said once are you going to go home and
tell your mother
that your company failed
if you grew up around silicon valley it
was like okay big deal what are you
going to do next but there's some places
in the country and in the world where
you know that that's going to be really
hard for you and if if it is and you
don't feel like you're up for it maybe
that's not where you ought to go
are the leaders of the startup
professionals or are they friends
i i put up a big red flag every time i
see a startup that's three college
roommates that get together because they
want to start a company and i'll be the
ceo and so you be the marketing vp and
what do you want to be okay uh
engineering yeah well we got to have one
okay well you're really not very good
that's a bad way to get a company
started
and if you get into a company where
where the
officers are friends
and they wouldn't be picked for their
talent in a fair fight against other
people
this has a very high probability of
coming out with the worst possible
outcome you could imagine which is you
lose the company you lose the job and
you probably lose your friends
uh in in in the process so i just say
massive caveats on going into any
startup
where a bunch of your friends get
together and choose upsides is the
financing solid for at least a year
because you don't want to be coming into
something
unless there's at least a year of runway
there before the company needs to raise
money
because maybe it won't and that's and
that's tough
as i said if it's a tough choice
say no
if it's a startup you want to be focused
on a couple of things and i say will you
be at the table
at the table
means are you going to be in the group
the small group of people that makes the
key decisions
that are in a closed room with the door
closed when something big is coming down
and bet the company are really important
decisions have to be made
if you're at that table it doesn't
matter a whole lot what your job title
is what your compensation is really or
anything else because it'll all be taken
care of
if you're not at the table
and you're outside looking through the
keyhole trying to figure out what's
going on in that room when the key
decisions are being made
i would say to you if to start up most
of the time the risk-reward ratio for
you is not right
you know that that puts you in the in in
the world of four box matrixes
in the high risk low reward box and i
don't think that's a box
that you ought to be intentionally
aiming yourself to
that if the company is wildly successful
you make a little bit of money
and you weren't really part of the the
team that drove it
on the other hand
if you're in the high risk high reward
box
yeah that could be great that's a mature
startup that's that's not a pure startup
from zero
uh if if they've done a series b and
they've got financing for
a year
or more and they're and they're growing
rapidly
then you might want to you might relax
that because they're going to be hiring
a lot of people and they're not all
going to have a a seat at the
um
at the key table then the the question
though
to ask is will i have a seat at some
interesting table
and
does the person that i'm going to be
working for maybe have a seat at the big
table
[Music]